J'ai vu dans l'avenir et j'ai
vu qu'aujourd'hui est un nouveau jour un jour plein
de filles Je souhaite juste je souhaite juste que
mes Russes veuillent bien d'
accord alors j'utiliserai ma torche pour mettre le feu
à la chambre  mignon j'ai bien compris celui-
ci alors j'utiliserai mes tortes d'accord
puis d'
accord puis j'utiliserai ma torche - d'
accord
je sais que c'est difficile c'est une
bande de fréquence difficile - vraiment j'aime comment je le fais bien
quand nous étions blessés  Oh mère, je ne connais pas
ma ligne Non,
c'est totalement contre les règles, je suis
désolé désolé
[Musique]
Oh ta mère a appelé, elle a besoin de toi
tout de suite, tout va bien
non non je ne
pense pas qu'il s'agisse d'une saison aussi folle d'accord tu as
ça c'est ta grand-mère je ne sais pas
c'est ta grand-mère j'aime ça aussi
[Musique]
je peux le
faire c'est une répétition on
roule  ça va commencer à partir de
[Musique]
c'est faux Hé nous avons un problème
maintenant, ça n'a pas l'air juste
oh désolé le tableau du bas
c'est arrivé à nouveau c'est juste littéralement juste
je suis tellement désolé les gars
je dois rentrer à la maison oh c'est ta grand-mère
quoi ouais
[Musique]
vous